DAVA NEWMAN: Hello,
I'm Dava Newman.
And when I served as NASA
Deputy Administrator--
that's the number two--
I became very familiar with
our Earth-observing satellites,
which tell us about the vital
signs of our planet, which
I call Spaceship
Earth, eyes on Earth
from this global perspective.
I saw warming
temperatures, melting ice,
intensifying natural disasters.
Climate change is real.
And if we're going to solve
climate change, the moon
shot of our generation,
we need everyone on board.
That's why with the support
of the MIT Portugal Program,
my partners and I
started EarthDNA, data
into action for the Earth.
We want to unite the whole
world in creating a sustainable
relationship between
humans and nature,
and we're so happy
to have you with us.
You'll be our
astronauts traveling
to places we could never
reach by ourselves,
and we'll be your
mission control,
providing you with
the tools and guidance
you need to make an impact
at the schools around you.
You'll teach students,
students will teach families,
and families will demand action.
With your help, we can
reach a destination,
a world that works
for 100% of humanity
without ecological offense.
We're ready for
liftoff, and we're
thrilled to have you on
board, so let's get started.
3, 2, 1, launch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]